you think they ready to say back then
would get a lot of guys playing that
white boy music and we really don't
listen to that you know and it's going
too fast to finally get to a place where
there is now a sea of all the rainbows
and people but a lot of black kids there
we're at the point of progress I hear
from a lot of people that call the safe
and you guys made it okay for me to feel
like it was alright to be black in the
rock I hear that a lot
Brooklyn's afro punk music festival was
born in 2005 for alternative black
culture but before there was a space for
celebration a strong handful of bands
were paving the way like the band
fishbone my name is and a little more
brought man a fishbone I'm John Norwood
Fisher basis for fishball fishbone was
formed in the late 70s and it was a Los
Angeles 1978 when two main bands who
look like this because all black band
playing punk rock and Scott we're
probably counting on one hand
the crazy part about it was while we
were starting to play a lot of rock and
roll we really weren't embraced too much
by the black public we were embraced a
lot by the white public so we get a lot
of white kids coming to the show
black people ain't supposed to play rock
that's not the stereotype like people
are supposed to play RB & funk and soul
if you got dreadlocks you suppose be
playing reggae and put on a suit and tie
you play there you play jazz right haha
afropunk is a celebration of rock and
roll black music for everyone it is
incredible and it draws in youth of
color to say this is for you and in a
larger way than we did you can be the
beautiful black you and rock
you